حضر رئيس مجموعه اكواس رئيس نيجيريا هولا
احمد تيليبو من ان رفضه قاده انقلاب
النيجر التجاوب مع مقترحات المجموعه سيفتح
الباب لتحرك ما سماها اطرافا خارجه عن
سيطره
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
الرساله التي يبعثها وضع قاده الانقلاب
الجيش في حاله تاهب وما هي الجهات الاخرى
التي تحذر اكواسمين تدخلها المحتمل في
النيجر من دون اذن المجموعه وما هي طبعا
خيارات فرنسا للتعامل مع قصيد قاده
الانقلاب ضدها
[موسيقى]
حاله التاهب القصوى للجيش
فيه معلومات وصلتهم انهم يتوقعون هجوم من
من
لذلك اظن استعدوا وايضا قد يكون هناك ما
يسمى بوسائل حرب الاعلام والدعايات خاصه
لباد الاحزاب المعارضه فلذلك استعد
البارحه كانوا بعضهم قالوا ممكن قبل الفجر
سيكون في هجوم على البلاد وشيء من هذا
القبيل وكذلك يتوقعون من فرنسا التي رفدت
سفيرها ان تغادر البلاد ان تهاجم هي
الدوله مستقله من منذ 1960 فاذا طالبت
بمغادره السفير من السفراء بغض النظر من
يحكم مفروض على الاقل يستجيب لما قالوا
احتراما لرغبه البلاد
الاستمرار في العمل الدستوري واذا كان
السفير قدم اوراق اعتماده امام الرئيس
بازون ولم يقدمه امام مجلس الحالي
وبالتالي فرنسا تعمل بموجب حقها الدست
وريه لديها اسلوب مختلف عن اسلوب طاري
فيما يتعلق بالتعامل مع النيجر وغرب
افريقيا كان لديها مهمه في النيجر قبل
اسبوعين واخفقت فيها تقريبا انها طردت
البلاد وبدون ان تقابل الرئيس بعزوم او
رئيس الانقلابيين
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا لان ما في هناك دوله تحدد
النيجر بالتدخل غير غير فرنسا بل كثير
يتهمون عنا فرنسا هي التي حتى مولت بعد
النفقات التدخل العسكري التي الذي يتزمه
منظمه اكواس نعم الاخوه ستكون بحاجه الى
عدد من القوات الغربيه لتقود هدايا الحمله
ولكن ليست فرنسا فرنسا سوف لن تقود اي
حمله اذا لم توافق الولايات المتحده على
ذلك هذا يعني انه حاليا ليس هناك احتمال
قيام الاكواس في عمل عسكري فرنسا ولديها
تاريخ طويل في التدخل في مستعمرات
الافريقيه القديمه هذه استعمرات استقلت
منذ 60 سنه وفرست تدخلت 50 مره في هذه
السنوات وبالتالي ما يريدونه الا انهم
يريدون التدخل لكن ليس
كفرنسا بل يريدون يكون بقي اده ايكواس ولا
نيجيريا انقلاب
هكذا في سبب لهذه الانقلابات وتلاحظ انها
في الدول الفرانكفونيه فقط التي استعملتها
فرنسا في غينيا في مالي في بوركينا فاسو
وفي النيجر فما ذلك في ختا في كيفيه
الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
فرنسا تريد عوده الرئيس فازون في ممارسه
صلاحيه التي صوت له شعب النيجر لكي يقوم
به الولايات المتحده تفضل الحل الدبلوماسي
وليس الحل بالقوه كما تدعو ذلك
وسبب ان الولايات المتحده تريد العمل بهذه
الطريقه هو له جانبين اولهما ان هناك
حوالي الف جندي امريكي في شمال النيجر
يقومون باعمال مكافحه الارهاب ولا يريدون
التضحيه والاطلاع هذه المهمه والثاني هو
ان الولايات المتحده ترى انها لو غادرت
النيجر فذلك سيخلق فراغا تحتل روسيا هو
مجموعه الموقف الامريكي والفرن متماثيلان
كلهم منهما يدعو الى حل ديبلوماسي تدعوان
الى الايكو او تدعوني الايكواس الى
التدخل من خلال الوساطه
لان جل الشعب ما درسوا اصلا الذي يهمنا
الذي يوفر لنا الامن والغذاء والتعليم
والصحه سواء كان عسكريا او كان مدنيا